Maria is passionate about coffee she
runs a cafe in aqua tile and she can
certainly make a mean espresso and
cappuccino her brews are considered
quite special in this small town I lived
for a while in Managua I used to go to
cafes there and always liked trying
different kinds of coffee but here in my
hometown there was no way you could do
that Maria gave up her job in the
capital and came home where she decided
to learn all about coffee I went to the
school out of curiosity I felt like
learning something new she went to the
National Coffee School which is also in
aqua tile it's part of a vocational
College and was set up ten years ago by
private investors and associations it's
300 students learn everything about
farming and processing coffee that
includes tasting learning how to detect
different flavours acidity and
bitterness and distinguish good coffee
from bad
[Music]
number three has a distinctive acidity
it tastes good Pleasant the others don't
have much taste at all you can really
tell the difference in quality between
the coffee's the National Coffee school
was officially accredited as a
vocational training facility last year
students don't pay any fees the school
is funded by the state trade
associations and NGOs fifty percent of
agricultural jobs in Nicaragua are
Coffee related so continuous training
including preparation methods is
important among the founders of the
school is Gonzalo Castillo he's been
growing coffee for over thirty years
with global coffee prices close to
rock-bottom modern farm management
techniques and sustainable production
can boost revenues a lot of the school
students come from coffee farming
families the skills objective is to help
producers increase their knowledge and
to find ways to make the coffee industry
more attractive and lucrative so that
the growers remain committed to the land
and don't move to the cities the course
takes a year and a half
students learn everything about coffee
from planting through harvesting to
preparing drinks they have to be able to
operate the machine that shells the
beans which by the way uses a lot of
water
Juan Francisco Martinez represents a
sustainable farming NGO called hoods it
supports the school financially and
certifies coffee plantations according
to social and environmental standards
their certificates allow producers to
demand higher prices for their beans but
he says coffee farmers face serious
threats climate change is real every day
we feel the temperatures rise it rains
when it should be dry precipitation is
much harder to forecast
it's estimated that nicaragua's coffee
crop will be down 20 to 30 percent this
year that's evident on Gonzalo
Castillo's plantation this winter his
Pickers brought in the last of the crop
two weeks earlier than usual because of
the high rainfall and high temperatures
the coffee plants are blossoming again
way ahead of schedule to harvest more
beans now would jeopardise next season's
crop almost all producers are facing
losses but not me so far thanks to God
and high-quality
the mark of quality is red the color of
ripe beans they're the ones that yield
the tastiest brews and command the
highest prices
Gonzalo Castillo pays his workers
one-year-old 30 for a bucket of red
beans that's quite a lot more than they
would get on other plantations in the
area he also employs single mothers
dominga cruz says other work is hard to
find I work here for three months during
the harvest and in summer I do other
jobs here I look after the soil
fertilize and water the tree nursery I'm
here all the time
Environmental Protection is essential
for a farm to keep its certificate from
oats the water used here to clean the
raw beans is now recirculated before it
eventually drains into a tank it used to
flow straight into a nearby stream the
workers also collect the bean husks and
make compost and organic fertilizer with
them Castillo has had an odd certificate
for two years now people know where this
coffee comes from from a plantation that
pays well with no child labor and that
is environmentally friendly that's why
I'm paid somewhat more for my coffee
five to ten percent more thanks to the
certification the environmental benefits
are also clear to see the stream used to
be black with waste from all the coffee
plantations
you